on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight sends a disgraced MP Matt
Hancock flees to the Jungle to become a
reality star to the man who failed to
protect our elderly through a deadly
pandemic and I'll be allowed to profit
from his infamy
train drivers doctors postal workers
barristers even coffee makers as Britain
is paralyzed by strikes I'll talk to the
union boss holding the country to Ransom
after the shocking attack on U.S speaker
Nancy Pelosi's husband I'm joined by the
top on crime senator who could challenge
Donald Trump for the presidential
nomination
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
well good evening Rolanda welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored Britain's had
its fair share of failed politicians
lately Boris Johnson lied more often
than he tried a last prime minister Liz
truss had the shelf life are they
lettuce and Theresa May's Legacy if only
we could remember it would fit very
neatly onto a postage stamp but few
politicians in modern history have
failed harder and more often than Matt
Hancock as attention seeking Perma
grinning gopher of a man is about to
appear and I'm a celebrity get me out of
here that means you'll spend several
weeks in a jungle in Australia pocketing
a massive fee on top of his MP salary
eating kangaroo testicles of public
detention I never thought I'd say this
but I actually feel sorry for the
kangaroo testicles I spent six years as
a judge on Britain and America's Got
Talent so another thing or two about
entertainment TV and talent and he got
me thinking why would they choose Matt
Hancock what are his special talents
maybe maybe it's singing
I believe
[Music]
no for the love of God do stop him now
he's not a singer what about acting look
very carefully here look for Tears
just simple words there reacting it
you're quite emotional about that it's
just it's been you know it's been such a
tough year for so many people and
there's William Shakespeare putting it
simply for everybody that you know we
can get on with our lives and yeah not a
single tear was it I've seen more
emotion from the wax works at Madame
tussos Matt's also a budding Tex whiz
earlier he became the first MP to enter
the metaverse with this digital
imagining of himself bringing a whole
new level of meaning to Instagram versus
reality
so finally what about his actual core
skill the one thing we know that he is
supposed to be competent at being a
politician the thing he's paid to do
well he was forced at his health
secretary for Snogging and groping his
advisor during a lockdown breaking his
own lockdown rules and before about a
sales secretary during the pandemic he
said he was doing this to protect
nursing homes
so right from the start we've tried to
throw a protective ring around our Care
Homes well we absolutely did throw a
protective ring around social care we'll
keep working to strengthen the
protective ring that we've cast around
all our Care Homes absolute nonsense
there was no protective ring quite the
opposite Hancock sent thousands of
elderly patients and hospitals back to
their nursing homes without testing them
that led to covid spreading the Wildfire
inside those homes causing countless
more deaths and should ever been allowed
to happen it was a deadly Fiasco of a
policy from a travesty of a health
secretary with tragic consequences for
thousands of families I may shock you
now Mr Hancock because I'm actually glad
you're going to remote
tarantula-infested jungle on the
opposite side of the world on behalf of
the entire British public I think I'm
safe in saying I hope you stay there
well joining me now to discuss is a
former liberal Democrat MP lemon oh
picky also went into I'm a celebrity and
the former conservative Minister and
Whitaker who I presume would rather
shoot herself and go into the jungle
though she did compete here strictly and
extremely capably on the dancer I might
add we're also joined by care home owner
David Crabtree now 16 of his residents
died in the first wave of the pandemic
well welcome to all of you I want to
start with you David Crouch because I
remember interviewing you at the heights
of the pandemic when so many people were
dying and you gave such a heartfelt uh
and agonized interview in many ways
about uh the appalling situation in Care
Homes when you heard that Matt Hancock
is going into the I'm a celebrity jungle
uh while you're still an MP what was
your view
before I I comment on that uh appears
can I thank you personally for being the
lone voice in early 2020 for social care
workers and social care residents there
was no one more shouting for us
as to Mr Hancock it's the last pitiful
Act of a pathetic lying man
there was no ring no protection for us
what's emotional is that when somebody
brings this up again
it brings back all the things that you
you sort of put to the back of your mind
we only this month we're able to have a
memorial for those who died in 2020
simply because relatives weren't allowed
to go to their funerals we weren't
allowed to see the relatives so for two
years we've never seen those families
again so we've just been able to sort of
at least bring that to a conclusion but
as to Mr Hancock
he lied there is no two ways about this
he lied 850 social care workers died on
top of thousands of elderly there were
collateral damage someone with his
permission gave the
hospitals the report to say you can
discharge and the with the without a
negative test
they do not need to be negative to
discharge they discharge two to us uh
within the first week of March and both
died and subsequently a further seven
died as a result of those discharges
directly
this man
oversaw this is this is Blair's Iraq
this is Hancock's uh death of elderly he
is solely responsible for it I'm still
angry
I can tell and you know you know what
angers me about all this is that while
some people have been sort of laughing
about this you know extraordinary twist
to his career it emerged today he's also
been taking part in the celebrity uh SAS
show on channel four he's already filmed
that he's also written a book of his
pandemic Diaries which I'm sure will be
an attempt to gloss over any of his
culpability because it wasn't just about
chaos he also failed and lied to the
public about testing he massaged those
figures about the number of tests that
were being done and we held him to
account for that I thought our open
border policy was a complete disaster
and he was partly responsible for that
as well as health secretary we had no
PPE so hundreds and hundreds of Health
and Care workers died in their workplace
because they weren't properly protected
this this first wave of the pandemic in
our country was a complete disaster and
it's completely true to say that later
we did well with vaccines but that first
wave was a disaster and the health
secretary presiding over this was Matt
Hancock and for him to now before
there's even been a proper inquiry into
what happened and what culpability he
may actually be proven to have had for
him to now go into an a reality show in
a jungle in the way that he's doing for
hundreds of thousands of pounds I think
is an absolute smack in the face
particularly to people like you who had
to go through so much appalling trauma
losing all these people in your homes
and I know other people I have friends
of mine who lost their parents in Care
Homes and had to have a last
conversation on FaceTime you know I just
think it's an appalling smack in the
face to them and and the idea he said an
MP receiving an MP salary is completely
disgraceful
I I couldn't agree more I I don't know
whether this is to pay the divorce
settlements or what it's supposed to do
but in the end it it should have all he
had to do was was say that we couldn't
do it or there was some reason that they
couldn't do it but instead contracts
were rewarded for PPE that were no use
to us we couldn't get them
more importantly they were discharging
elderly people to Hope back to home
where home care workers were going in
without PPE without the knowledge that
they had that the resident had covered
he put at risk
millions of people and then denied it
and and had the blessed to stand there
and say he had put a ring of protection
around us not once but several times the
man needs to be held account yeah I
agree uh David it's good to talk to you
I wish it was always in better
circumstances but I love your passion I
love the how much you care about what
happened in your care homes and it's
good to catch up with you I'm just sorry
again it's for the wrong reasons but I
look forward to talking to you perhaps
on a happier occasion
thank you
well let's bring in I mean Ann yeah I
don't know what you think to me the idea
of an MP particularly one who's been
disgraced who's lost his ministerial
position because he was breaking his own
lockdown rules whilst having an affair
and was caught doing it by uh by a
newspaper that had also presided over a
shambolic first wave of this pandemic by
any yardstick there's been no inquiry
yet which has cleared him as he
presumably hopes it might do but I don't
think it will you put all this in
totality and he's now
getting hundreds of thousands of pounds
to go into a jungle and prance about
with celebrities what do you make of it
well what I would say is that even
without all those horrendous
circumstances no serving MP should go on
a reality show which takes them away
from their constituency and from the
House of Commons where they're paid to
vote uh it takes them away for weeks on
it I mean you know weekend here at a
week if that's different weeks on end
and that is why I turned down strictly
for five years running I said no as soon
as I retired I said yes because I wanted
to do it but I wasn't going to do it
while I was an MP and it's not only time
that something else appears dignity you
do actually have a duty of dignity to
the office while you're an MP and
there's nothing dignified about the job
well okay what about his constituents
right this guy is already heaped
embarrassment onto his constituency
right he's managed to hang on as an MP
uh but this is as I say not this I'm a
celebrity he's managed to find time to
write a book of Diaries he's managed to
find time to do this SAS Show on Channel
4. now he's going in the jungle when is
he finding any time to do the job he's
actually paid to do on a daily basis
serve the constituents direct answer to
that question that doesn't matter for
his constituents at the next election
and I've got experience of this I may or
may not have lost my seat in 2010. why
isn't it a matter for me as a taxpayer
well if it pays his salary you can have
an opinion but we have a democratic
system here just as in 2010 Montgomery
should decided they didn't want many
more for whatever reason so also his
constituents in our democratic system
can make the Judgment no I no Anne's
position and I respect it I hold a
different view here you've just heard
what sounds like a tragic performance as
a cabinet minister that's different to
the principle which Anne rightly raises
about whether you should be able to do
these extended programs on reality TV
now surely no one disagrees with the
principle of a politician doing a
reality show have I got news for you
it's a comedy the show Vince cable very
popular politician did do a little bit
of dancing
have I got used to you it's a three-hour
taping of a Thursday night right this
guy is disappearing off for weeks to
Australia right when we're in the middle
of a crushing cost of living crisis
could be four weeks
all right so the first point he's being
paid by us the taxpayer not to not to go
and eat kangaroo testicles let me ask
you this lemon who is going to cope if
there is an emergency in his
constituency or a constituent has an
emergency where does that constituent go
yeah I work on the assumption that if
there's I and I don't know this but I've
been told this by Secondhand Authority
that there is some clause which says if
there's an emergency of a sufficiently
serious nature which is a judgment call
he would sorry there is it's called the
cost of living all right millions of
people in this country are currently
facing a winter of hunger you know of
freezing cold we've got pensioners going
on buses
because I I do have experience with this
let me just ask you this a constituent
gets in touch with the MP because the
electricity is about to be cut off
they've got kids in the house this has
happened and it probably happened with
you as well and when that sort of thing
happens you need the MP his staff don't
have the quote right two two points I'm
not switching on TV earlier then but I
won't be look we've been trying to
answer your questions I know but you're
trying to defend the indefensive you
don't know what I'm going to say well I
do know what you said earlier on
television I don't watch the interview
go on you compared him to Winston
Churchill you said Winston Churchill
also made mistakes and came back and won
US the Winston church do you think
Winston Churchill would go into a jungle
with a bunch of zedless celebrities a
Munch kangaroo testicles in a vote by
the public I was one of those that
that's listed yes exactly but I wasn't
nothing yes second but you don't know
Winston Churchill either
I've never pretended to be first point
that let's recognize no one here on the
three of us is denying that you could do
reality shows you're arguing about the
length of time away yes so let's move
straight to that second point that
Anne's raised if you're on holiday with
your family as an MP the same situation
can arise does that mean that the MP has
something to fly back okay you can pick
up right so it's not about physically
businesses
not in recess all right well let's
remember that but you can pick up the
phone if you're on holiday I've had to
do that as well okay some MPS have had
to come back from their holidays so
number one it's not about whether you do
reality shows it's the length of time
number two it's not about being
physically present as answer said so
it's the third question is it is
it enough of them you don't have phones
in the jungle okay vote remotely is that
enough of an obstruction to say that no
politicians should do that yes
absolutely I don't agree and here's why
not but I'm actually going to tell you
most things that do turn up in your
surgery are handled de facto certainly
for
serving members of parliament go on
jollies to Australia
how do you vote from the jungle when
there's a big issue in Poland
well I don't know if he's got a pairing
Center
you can still vote yeah okay so explain
that for me if you have the whip taken
away then you can still you're not
expelled from what's the punishment
really well if if you have the whip
withdrawn what it means is you're no
longer regard it as a member of the
party but you can still vote in
Parliament as an individual so where why
is he not going to be voting then well
obviously because he's not physically
there he doesn't need to be physically
he does let's get to the core Point here
you listed all the things he's doing my
guess is he's trying to change his
career he may not stand at the next
level I think he's ending as well maybe
so it was going to happen maybe they're
going to make him do the worst possible
challenges and then very quickly maybe
so but think about it this way right
you're mixing up his is performance as a
cabinet minister with the principle of
whether any politics
I'm actually saying both to me are
disqualifying right one he was the
health secretary they're two different
things about well I'm explaining to you
why both matter right on one count he
was the health secretary presided over
the worst imaginable pandemic conduct by
government I've seen which is why we had
the worst overall death toll in Europe
in terms of total number killed mostly
in the first wave one he should be held
accountable that before he jollies off
to some jungle and secondly as a serving
MP where we pay a salary he should not
be doing that that's all right on the
first point we can now pass judgment
about uh Matt Hancock perfectly
legitimate political conversation to
have but it's separate to me separate to
the point that Anne's raised where I
disagree but I respect you about whether
you can go on the next step
is how does he vote which is his
constitutional Duty as a member
did you vote on every single vote were
you there on Fridays for a German
debates
the worst thing about that Private
Matter the worst thing about it is I
think he waited there was a a an
absolutely
cringe-making clip of Rishi sunac
celebrating becoming prime minister I
don't know if we've got it and it's the
one where he basically goes past and
this is the second we've got it
and you know what all right he
completely deliberately sangs Hancock
there but the reality is you'll see what
you want to see no he doesn't I know I
know if you've seen that trust me he saw
him he started a blanket so but the
point being though if if he hadn't if
he'd embraced Hancock and given him a
new job Hancock would have immediately
abandoned all plans to go to the Jungle
so why should he not be pragmatic about
his future peers wasn't he being honest
and stand down and he's got two more
years it's honest about him making that
judgment back to my original point would
you have an answered why don't you think
that's how democracy democracy Works in
this country we elect members of
parliament we the taxpayers pay their
salaries and the very least we expect is
they serve their constituents and they
turn up and vote neither of which he can
do for up to four weeks in Australia
while he's on this ridiculous vanity
exercise of assuming the British public
will suddenly warm to his creepy little
self and vote for him they're not
they're going to vote for him to do
applicable things and then kick him out
because Azan said Azan admitted and I
admit we didn't make it for every single
vote a good a good percentage was about
60. he's made a judgmentally the judge
what he's made to be us like he's made
many times actually in the last few
years to be utterly self-serving to do
what he thinks is best for Matt Hancock
not anybody else and the result is a
slap in the teeth to the British
taxpayers at a moment when millions of
them are facing the worst cross-living
crisis of their of their lifetime
appeals hang on last word to you yes
you've said we didn't all attend every
single vote that is quite true but we
all took judgments on the votes we
attended and let me give you an example
when I was actually moving house that
was the night there was a vote on post
offices I actually got assistance to
move the house while I went to the vote
on post offices if there's a big vote
while he's in the jungle what does he do
yeah well stays in the jungle I've got
to leave it there look I
in a way limit you're the perfect
example of why you shouldn't be doing
this because your political career could
have been restored you could have
actually rebuilt your career and you
were a very capable politician but the
moment you see munching the old kangaroo
nuts
now Dean Doris did it and she's never
recovered either oh well come on come on
she got into the cabinet she didn't even
went to the cabinet
thank you for coming in I appreciate it
good to see you both we're coming next
to train drivers doctors postal workers
barristers nurses teachers uh coughing
workers just about everybody in Britain
appears we want to go out and strike and
I'll talk to Britain's top Union boss
who is presiding over this Mayhem and
from the firebomb attack on the UK
migrants into the shocking camera
assault on the U.S speaker Nancy
Pelosi's husband is critical violence on
the rise of what's behind me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to physical nonsense the
biggest rail strikes in decades of
course recurring chaos for communities
across Britain several more planned
beginning this weekend this year's
already seen walkouts by postal workers
dot workers at bull staff being
collectors barristers bus drivers even
coffin makers teachers nurses and
doctors could be an escalation ambulance
staff but at the strike later today so
I'll bring Britain's newly boisterous
unions testing the resolve of a
penny-pinching government rather just
annoying and aggravating the patients of
working people who are just as squeeze
as they are well joining me now is
General Secretary of the Trade union
Congress Francis oh greatly well thank
you very much for coming in first of all
your reaction to Matt Hancock choosing
to take hundreds of thousands of pounds
as a serving MP to fly all the way
across the world to Australia to much
kangaroo testicles
well uh I think probably pretty similar
to yours peers in that frankly if
anybody else in a job walked off the job
to Moonlight and get paid a huge amount
they'd have no chance should he
basically be should he be out as an MP
well to be honest I think there are many
people many working people would like to
see the whole lot of them go off to the
Jungle right but on this specific point
it should Matt Hancock be kicked out as
an MP I I think people have right to
question how does he stay in his job
when any other ordinary person right so
he should be fine I'd like to see him
fight whatever the Democratic process is
but surely I mean this this is the man I
heard you talking before not only
promised this protective ring frankly he
should be preparing his defense
absolutely should be with lawyers but
but it was those social care workers
were not only wrapping themselves in bin
bags most of them earn less than 10
pounds an hour and a huge numbers of
them are on zero as contract that's why
they were moving around between
different homes unwittingly spreading
them and he let all the elderly and
hospitals go back to their Care Homes
without being tested and meanwhile PPE
contracts and other contracts were being
handed to mates yeah people have been
using the local pub
um let's turn to you because you're I
mean depending on who you talk to people
are either supportive of what you're
doing presiding over all these strikes
or they think you're as annoying as Matt
Hancock because a lot of ordinary
people's lives are being directly
impacted in a negative way at an
incredibly difficult time by this
blizzard of strike action yeah and what
I'm very clear about is I have not met a
single worker who's voted for strike
action lightly you lose pay it's the
last resort any trade unionist wants the
employer to get around the table and
negotiate a fair deal but one of the
reasons why we've had unprecedented
public support for these strikes is that
all working people are facing the same
cost of living in crisis and this isn't
just this year this has been 10 years of
stagnating pay and real pay cuts nurses
thousands of pounds worse off than they
were 10 years ago paramedics teachers
people have just hit the limit I mean
one person
but one person hasn't done uh nearly as
badly as that has done around the world
is you Francis O'Grady gave yourself pay
Rises of 18 000 pounds since 2013 that
was just to 2018. I haven't had to pay
you guys for the last four years your
gross salary is 112 000 pounds a year
and the total package 167 000 pounds a
year
um I mean if you think you're in the top
three percent of earners your package is
equivalent to 22 times the average
amount for recipient of Universal Credit
do you feel comfortable about that I'm a
trade unionist I believe that people
should get paid the rate for the job I
think you should get paid the rate for
the job I don't know what you're on but
I'm leading an organization that
represents
I understand but you think that you
should be getting 22 times the average
recipient of Universal Credit
in the TUC the pay ratio bottom to top
I'm getting paid I think a fair rate for
the job but most of all who's the lowest
paid person number to use it we directly
employ all our staff so who's the lowest
the cleaners what would they get they
get more than the London living wage so
what would they get
what is your lowest earning employee get
um where it's we only have one employee
on less than 15 pounds an hour so you've
got an employee on less than 15 pounds
an hour you're raking in 167 Grand it's
not bad is it I mean my point is you're
talking a lot about how much you care
about people's pay packets as well all
these strikes are necessary and yet
there's a gap of somebody on your staff
earning under 15 pounds you're hoovering
up 167. the average CEO version full
well yeah and if you look at bonuses
running trades
you're in charge of the trades unions
wouldn't it be a great gesture to say
wouldn't it be great to say you know
what I'm actually going to set an
example and half my salary but I'll tell
you what peers
under 15. now on the TUC is why are the
four biggest banks in Britain making 33
billion pounds worth of profit and the
government is
let's talk about the real issues and why
it is that we're going to have thousands
why don't you target them thousands of
workers right Westminster tomorrow
lobbying the government and saying I
know we've kept the limit by the way I
agree with you lobbying the government I
agree with you going after the bankers
over this ridiculous decision to release
the cap on their bonuses it was the
bonuses that got us into that into 2008
nine financial crash I agree with you
going after energy companies right
exactly what we should be doing what I
don't agree with is this unbelievable
ripple effect of strikes which is now
really destabilizing the country
black coal in our finances
wine mate life even more difficult for
people already suffering it's my point
inflation is running at over 10 RPI is a
lot higher if you take into account more
so how can we afford how can we afford
the government to give everybody
whacking pay Rises they caused the
crisis I know and it's about time they
made the wealthy and big business pay
their I don't disagree with you and that
but surely you're not expecting
everybody to be are you expecting
everyone that you represent in totality
to get enough money to cover the
inflation do you know what peers if you
equalize capital gains tax with income
tax that would cover an entire pay rise
for the entire do you want them all to
be paid in line with inflation that
would cover it right that would cover do
you want everyone to get a 10 if we were
more ambitious boldering on the windfall
tax on greedy energy companies if we did
something about those four big Banks 33
billion pounds think what difference
that would make I mean some people would
some people would say again it's all
very welcome for you for us a great 167
Grand I don't you like one of The
Greener Bankers yourself package they're
on a hell of a lot more than that
pierces and I'm sure you are too it was
a very nice package isn't it you know
I'm representing this is the head of the
cuc because I believe you're taking a
little bit less I believe in the rate
for the job and that's what nurses
teaching and you get even more than math
social care workers well on the jungle I
don't think so I think he's on a bit
more than that but the point hit this I
mean that I think you're being a bit
trivial here because the point is I
don't think your salary is true millions
of workers who deserve I understand that
and I agree that at least keeps up with
inflation and that's why but also as
you've said to me difficult I know
you've also said to me you have one of
your own employees on less than 15 hours
what about taking somebody or 167 Grand
what about the government what about you
doing what you want the government to do
and be fair to your poor employee who's
earning under 15 grand 15. we are very
fair I think we you think that's
something do you feel comfortable really
yes we we don't know why don't you give
that employee a little bit of your you
don't why don't you talk about set an
example I've decided today Francis
O'Grady that the best way to show the
government you've got to spread the
money around is I'm going to spread some
of my last Fortune myself we have a much
lower ratio top to bottom than any other
167 Grand to 15 quid an hour yes I know
wow that's pretty I mean that's we're
talking about most CEOs I've already got
arms big enough for that Gap how much
more do you earn than the cleaners I'm
not the head of the TUC no but if we've
got a sense of I'm not demanding that
everyone goes on strike I'm not out
there causing Mayhem with shutting down
Railways and everything else here you go
peers will you support our Westminster
here's what I do I will personally match
pound for pound every pound from your
salary you give the poor person to you
see earning on the 15th I'm tempted I
will match it half a pound deal we'll
talk about that okay we have a deal
everybody thank you very much well
coming up next President Biden says
there's too much hatred and too much
political violence in America is he
right and if so who is to blame I'll be
asking the man who could challenge
Donald Trump for the presidential
nomination
and to stop oil strikes again you know
what I'm sick of them as well why don't
we just shut up about him look at him
childish little toddlers throwing
Tantrums Mike come and do it in my
studio come on see how you get on then
[Music]
right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the 42 year old us man who's been
charged with attempting to kidnap Nancy
Pelosi the third most senior politician
in America David bappa raided the
speaker's home of San Francisco attacked
her 82 year old husband with a hammer
his motive is yet to be disclosed but
police say it wasn't random it comes
just months after an alleged
assassination attempt on Supreme Court
Justice Brett Kavanaugh raising fresh
concerns about political violence and
already very polarized country President
Biden today condemned the attack
the chant was
where's Nancy where's Nancy where's
Nancy
enough is enough is enough every person
of good conscience
needs to clearly and unambiguously
stand up against the violence in our
policies regardless what your politics
are
well join me now the Republican
sentences for Arkansas
Senator thank you very much indeed for
joining me I appreciate it what was your
reaction to What President Biden said
there
well first off I condemn the violent
attack on Paul Pelosi I wish him well I
hope he has a full recovery we should
throw the book uh at his assailant just
like we should throw the book at all
violent criminals not those who not just
Those who commit crimes against the
powerful and the wealthy but people who
are pushing New Yorkers in front of
subway trains or committing carjackings
uh or committing murders too often we
have gone soft on crime in this country
in recent years and I think that's
contributed to the crimeway we've had
but if Joe Biden wants to be serious
about political violence why didn't he
have his own Department of Justice
enforce the law this summer when you had
left-wing agitators protesting in front
of Supreme Court Justices homes in
direct violation of federal law which
culminated with a deranged left-wing
Hitman traveling from California trying
to assassinate Brett Kavanaugh I condemn
that just as strongly and think we
should throw the book at him as well I
don't disagree with you I would agree
with you about that I suppose my
question would be what should we throw
the book also at people who are
political either politicians or you know
budding politicians have big public
profiles who make a mockery of incidents
like the appalling attack on Paul Pelosi
would you would you throw the book at
that as well
well there were words though unwise and
unhelpful to healthy debate are
protected by the First Amendment
um look there's a lot of heated rhetoric
and campaign but pointing out that Nancy
Pelosi passed Obamacare 12 years ago or
has spent trillions of dollars we don't
haven't contributed this inflation has
no bearing whatsoever on this but I
wasn't actually referring to that I was
actually referring to this this or two
clips actually one is the Arizona
governor candidate Carrie Lake who said
this in response to what happened
it is not impossible to protect our kids
at school
they act like it is Nancy Pelosi well
she's got protection when she's in DC
apparently her house doesn't have a lot
of protection
I mean hearing an audience laugh out
loud at such a crass comment you must
share my horror of that don't you
well Piers again rhetoric on the
campaign trail that it that may be tough
uh does not contribute to this kind of
violence it's if anything what you heard
there what you've heard from Republicans
about Nancy Pelosi pales in contrast say
what Chuck Schumer selling the steps of
the Supreme Court that Brett Kavanaugh
wouldn't know what hit him if he issued
rulings that Chuck Schumer yeah I don't
listen I I'm Not For a Moment defending
anything else that you've been talking
about and I think they've all been
appalling incidents but for instance
Donald Trump Jr put a Halloween tweet
out which he then deleted which said
this
this is a picture as you can see there
of a hammer on a pair of Underpants and
Donald Trump Jr tweeted the internet
remains undefeated and if you switch out
the hammer for a red feather boa you
could be Hunter Biden in an instant now
again I would simply say that
if you're gonna you know say that we've
got to throw people out for bad behavior
bad commentary bad whatever these are
just to me extraordinarily crass things
to be doing in the light of an elderly
man who who happens to be the husband of
the United States Speaker who was nearly
killed in this attack from all accounts
this is not a subject for humor is it
well appears I I can only tell you what
I think it is I think it's a heinous
attack and we should be throwing the
book at people who commit these violent
acts whether against Paul Pelosi or
Brett Kavanaugh or just ordinary
Americans something may something that
politicians may say In the Heat of the
campaign you could think it's crass or
that it's poorly poor judgment but it's
not the same as committing these acts no
no listen I'm Not For a Moment I'm Not
For a Moment saying it's the same I just
think it would be really helpful I speak
because I'm in a country right now
Britain where two members of parliament
have been murdered by crazy people in
the last six years and I'm extremely
worried as someone who has a house in in
America spends a lot of time over there
loves the country loves the people I'm
very worried that the temperature of
political debate is reaching the kind of
levels which we had here over brexit and
other incendiary issues which caused
crazy people to do crazy things to our
politicians and I don't want to see the
next bit of news that we see in America
being an actual politician has been
murdered by a crazy person because the
rhetoric being hurled around by people
and the lack of seriousness taken by
political figures when these things
happen as well by the way that all this
it doesn't help does it isn't it time
that everybody dial things down
well Pierce I think you could have tough
campaigns you can have spirited debates
but you can also be civil and respectful
now I think in many of these cases
unfortunately like it would appear with
the Paul Pelosi incident or Gabby
Giffords incident more than a decade ago
you're dealing with someone who has
serious mental health issues as well
which there's a different set of public
policy questions but I think it's best
that we have spirited debates but
debates that are respectful and civil
and recognize that we're all Americans
or in your case all British and that we
can have disagreements that we can
settle those disagreements through our
rep elected representatives or at The
Ballot Box yeah I can endorse that um no
Senator you've got an extraordinary
background you served in Iraq with 101st
Airborne Division and in Afghanistan
with a provincial reconstruction team uh
between combat tools you serve with the
third infantry regiment the Old Guard at
Arlington National Cemetery which I've
been to which is a remarkable place
um so I really uh commendable military
career and I wanted to ask you
specifically about one part part of
what's going on in the world right now
involving Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and what the recently deposed British
prime minister Boris Johnson said today
about the nuclear threat which Putin
keeps making
I don't think he will I think he'd be
crazy to to do so what would happen is
that he would immediately tender
Russia's resignation from the club of
civilized Nations it would be a total
disaster for his country
what did you make of that comment
well I tend to agree with Boris I know
that Vladimir Putin has rattled the
nuclear saber we've seen no indication
of him taking kind of steps to use
nuclear weapons nor can we allow the
nuclear threat to allow him to Blackmail
the United States or blackmail the West
you know I've got a new book out called
Only the Strong and I write about
exactly this kind of threat throughout
the Cold War you know Ronald Reagan took
a very strong assertive stance against
Soviet Russian communism
even though the nuclear threat then was
just as dangerous as it is now we have
to be strong we have to be Resolute in
the defense of America's national
interests and as you saw time and time
again with Ronald Reagan that kind of
strength and resolution didn't lead to
nuclear war it didn't lead to World War
III it led to Victory and success in the
Cold War there are Republicans it's
quite interesting I've just been in
America actually I went to New York L.A
and talked to a lot of people
Republicans do some do something about
Ukraine and about how far America should
be going to help the ukrainians some
Republicans bang up for it and think
that they should be you know giving him
whatever he needs president zelenski to
win the war recognizing perhaps The
Wider threat to the to the world
including America if Putin was to win
but other other Republicans and I'm
quite surprised about this I've taken a
view that it's not really in America's
interests to get involved in this
conference at all what's your view
well I think it is in our interest to
support the ukrainians fighting in their
own War to defend their own territory uh
that's what we've been doing from the
beginning if we had done it earlier and
if Joe Biden had granted so many
concessions to Vladimir Putin in 2021 I
don't think he would have been tempted
to go for the jugular in Ukraine in the
first place I go into great detail about
this in Only the Strong and when I'm
traveling across Arkansas when I'm
traveling on the campaign Trail Across
America I hear that most Americans want
to continue to support the ukrainians
who are fighting their own War there is
frustration they don't think enough uh
European nations are doing their part
now there are some weapons that only
America has that only we can provide but
when it comes to financial aid for the
government in Ukraine there's certainly
a lot of nations in Europe that could be
doing more to help pull their share of
the load finally uh Senator I was going
to let you plug your book you've done
that very comprehensively and very
impressively I must say several times I
won't bother um although I've told it's
a great read
um I do want to ask you though if if as
is suspected there's a red wave in the
midterms next week and I I think it's
pretty clear now that that is probably
going to happen there's going to be a
lot of speculation about who will be the
Republican candidate in the next general
election in 2024 and your name is being
thrown around with more Gusto can you
say definitively whether you would be
interested in running to be president
well Pierce I appreciate the question I
think I'll keep my focus on the election
that's just a few days away rather than
the elections that two years away but I
will say this anyone running for
president in the Republican Party who
wants to help restore American strength
and power in the world should get
themselves a copy of Only the Strong and
learn exactly how to do that
shoehorn the most mentions of their book
title into one eight minute interview
you sir are heading to the white house
uh Senator I appreciate you coming on
thank you very much
thank you pierce
well coming next it's World vegan day uh
always a day that I celebrate with huge
enthusiasm uh and they're in my pack a
clutching a vegan sausage roll from
Greg's uh one of my favorites we'll be
discussing that after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back I'm joined by talk TV
contributors Esther Cracklin and Paula
Brown Adrian and very sadly they brought
with them some sausage rolls uh one of
which is a real one which I will be
eating for my supper later and the other
one is a Greg's vegan sausage roll which
remains as inedible as you could
possibly imagine any food product to be
but it's well vegan day if that rocks
your boat go and see a doctor which is
what most vegans most vegans look like
they need to
um welcome to my pack I want to start
with just something's a bit of fun but
it is a bizarre thing to happen James
cord who's been in the news a lot um
over his bus stop in a restaurant
yeah yeah
um so he did a joke on Halloween night
on his show in America and then people
thought hang on we've heard that before
and this is the mashup
because if someone puts up a poster in a
town square that says guitar lessons
available that's like going into a Town
Square seeing a big notice board and
there's a notice guitar lessons like you
don't get people in the town go I don't
want to play the guitar and you go but I
don't want guitar lessons
mine wasn't for you it was for somebody
else you don't have to get mad about all
of it time it's not for you then just
walk away
it's not great
my theory this is the secret omelette
lover in the in the writing team he's
basically slipped in one there right
absolutely but let's not talk about that
it's just a bit of fun really um I want
to talk about Elon Musk taking over
Twitter we're all on Twitter right yeah
and today's announced that it's going to
be eight dollars a month to have your
blue tick about seven pounds to have
your blue tick and with that you get a
few benefits on top ability to edit
tweets and so on would you pay it oh
absolutely yeah I think you would I
think yeah it makes sense as a business
model as well because then you know the
site isn't beholden to just advertisers
saying we're going to boycott you
because you haven't de-platformed this
person yeah or it does it takes the
power out of the advertisers and put it
puts it back into the user's hands
because only one percent of Twitter
actually it has over a thousand
followers right even a fraction of that
have blue ticks yeah he also thinks it
will get rid of a lot of the Bots and
stuff because people will want to pay
this or want to be part of the Bluetooth
Thing by doing that you have to identify
exactly who you are and everything else
yeah and that's important to be be able
to be challenged because surely that's
what Twitter is all about you want your
voice to be heard but also you have to
have the right to be challenged and I
think I think that's what's really
important about this and actually I
think that's probably a good thing I
mean Elon Musk is he great think about
him is he's an absolute creative
Whirlwind genius absolutely I think that
goes without saying already he seems to
be getting under the Bonnet of Twitter
yeah and working out how to a make it a
functional better functioning uh
platform but also to make a lot of money
out of it which is what he's brilliant
at doing and I've got no problem with
that because the Bedrock of what he
wants to do is to restore what he calls
a more balanced conversation and
allowing people with different views I
mean we know that mainly conservative
views yeah are the ones that have been
suppressed right absolutely and I think
this is the thing sorry how do we how do
we know that well because actually
they're the ones that are mostly getting
banned you actually don't see many
people let's get banned and actually I
see some of the left do unspeakably
nasty stuff on Twitter and they get away
with it because they're on the left and
I'm not one I don't call for censorship
because I don't really care for them I
don't think it should be a playground
where it's supposed to be Tit for Tat I
think these platforms should be exactly
that platforms you should have everyone
should have a voice you shouldn't
disproportionately favor one or the
other because if that at that point
you're not a platform you're a publisher
that's what I'm really happy about I
love the fact that Elon Musk has annoy
so many people they're like we're
leaving Twitter who are you I I've lost
a lot of followers in the last few
months and then they've all come surging
back exactly Elon Musk but on Twitter I
don't know why yeah probably a
coincidence or maybe the Twitter wokies
have been stopped doing what they were
doing to any one of these views they
don't like like people attacking their
vegan sausage rolls but I'm currently on
seven million 999
104 followers which means tonight
the big eight Millions coming in I'm
going to wake up to a big eight million
and there's going to be an 8 million
party on this show tomorrow
how many of you how many followers
how many followers have you both about
eight million
um
eight and a half yeah I'm gonna check
before if you don't want to sell it no I
don't have about eight million yeah yeah
I'm about 1300. 1300 I think so yeah
I want to alarm you I don't need to
check my email you're 57 000.
I'm missing half of my family members
yeah yeah is ultimately a Force for good
or bad are we all being sent completely
nuts by it I'll be too addicted to it
we're far too addicted yeah I think I am
far too Addicted by it we're far our
egos are simply left to run wild and
that is the problem with Twitter and I
on a serious note I hope Elon Musk can
rain in slightly and I think you can
because I'm not sure that Donald Trump
is going to last very long I don't think
he'll even go back on Twitter I don't
think it serves his purpose anymore oh
of course he will
say yes I don't see the incentive behind
it but I think I don't think Twitter is
a forceful kid as a as a currently is
because I don't think most people trust
it like they don't we talk about a force
for evil which is the stop the oil
cretins who've been up doing their thing
they actually attacked our building
using Taylor with their paint they've
attacked Downing Street today they are
the biggest toddlers in World protesting
history and I keep saying this and they
don't want to hear it none of us are
actually being moved to follow their
cause by this pathetic Behavior and the
police should be doing more to stop them
Pierce what was the purpose we've run
out of time
thank you guys that's it for me what
you're up to keep it on censored good
night
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]